the return of the king king charles iii
among the people outside buckingham
palace his new official residence
welcome everyone to entertainment
tonight you know the passing of queen
elizabeth made headlines around the
world she graced newspaper covers all
over the globe katie nichol is outside
the palace with new details on a nation
in mourning
[Music]
96 fell tolls 96 rounds fired in a gun
salute and thousands here at buckingham
palace today as the new king charles iii
greeted mourners with his queen consort
camilla one mourner even gave him a kiss
this before addressing the nation for
the first time as king
i speak to you today
with feelings of profound sorrow
a source close to the royal family tells
e.t charles camilla and princess anne
all were able to see the queen before
she died her grandsons were not both
harry and william left balmoral today
harry departed first after 12 hours of
honoring his grandmother rushing to a
flight he was seen comforting an airport
worker who shared condolences what does
it say about the royal rift well i think
the fact that he left at 8 30 speaks
volumes and it he left alone he arrived
alone
and i think there is a great sense of
pain grief and loneliness about prince
harry we understand he's returned to be
with megan at their windsor residence
frogmore cottage this comes as harry and
megan's children have automatically
become prince archie and princess
lillabet although as king charles could
revoke those titles archie being called
the prince was that important to you if
it meant he was going to be safe then of
course i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas while he addressed harry and
meghan with great warmth he didn't
acknowledge them by their official
titles the duke and duchess of sussex i
think there is significance in that
charles also brought up william and
kate's new titles as my heir
william today i am proud to create him
prince of wales with catherine beside
him our new prince and princess of wales
i'm told by palace sources that
catherine is very well aware of the
title that she has now inherited
everyone will compare her to the last
princess of wales i suspect that
catherine's success will be making that
title her own
we will always celebrate her life
remember what she stood for
late night held up a mirror to the
public's differing reactions everything
from how will the kingdom carry on all
the way to you shouldn't have colonized
india bye
jimmy kimmel brought some levity this
week she saw harry styles spit on chris
pine and said okay i've had enough
join me in a round of applause for 70
years of service
he's been
with me all my life and i feel very sad
and yeah from harry styles to elton john
musicians pay tribute and we celebrate
our life tonight with music okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and now we're all wrecking our brains as
to what to give you to show our
appreciation
and in a sign of reverence the crown
which has been shooting princess diana
scenes paused production a rep tells et
filming was suspended today and will
also be suspended on the day of her
majesty the queen's funeral that state
funeral will possibly be on september
the 19th at westminster abbey the
country has entered a 10-day period of
national mourning and tomorrow charles
will be officially proclaimed king at 73
charles is the oldest monarch that this
country has had and it's going to be
very hard to fill the queen's shoes and
i think actually charles does have the
potential to be a very popular king with
queen consort camilla by his side
[Music]